Es scheint so gut wie sicher: Wir werden andere
Planeten besuchen und höchstwahrscheinlich
werden wir den Weltraum auch demnächst zu
einem dauerhaften Außenposten der Menschheit
machen.
Doch wer wird das tun?
Spielen NASA, ESA und andere stattliche Weltraumagenturen
dann noch eine Rolle?
Oder wird es wie im Internet: Private Unternehmen
übernehmen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes die
Macht?
Clixoom Science & Fiction; Hier gibt es täglich
spannende Sciencevideos.
ASbonniert den kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen
vielen lieben Dank für diesen tollen Themenvorschlag
bei Whats App!
Gucken wir einmal kurz zurück in die Geschichte
der Raumfahrt: In ihren Anfängen waren es
vor allem die USA und die Sowjetunion, die
wirklich Wahnsinns Raumfahrt Missionen in
die tat umgesetzt haben.
Zwischen 1950 und 1970 schickte man Menschen
ins All und auf den Mond; dabei waren kurz
vorher erst Raketen erfunden worden.
Doch damals ging es ausschließlich darum,
Raketen als Trägersystem für Atomwaffen
einzusetzen.
Die Visionen von bemannten Raumflügen waren
damals nicht geplant.
Erst 1955 ging dazu der Wettlauf los: Sputnik
wurde ins All geschickt; dann kam die Hündin
Laika und dann Yuri Gagarin.
Dann die Landung auf dem Mond 1969 der absolute
Hammer und das bis heute.
Seitdem gibt es bemannte Raumfahrt nur noch
im erdnahen Weltraum.
Rückblickend gesehen war das “Goldene Zeitalter”
der Raumfahrt ausschließlich politisch motiviert.
Kaum war der Wettlauf gewonnen, war er auch
schon vorbei.
Doch auch diese Zeiten sind vorbei und der
Weltraum und das Sonnensystem werden kontinuierlich
erforscht.
Doch fest steht auch: Die staatlichen Raumfahrtorganisationen
können nicht mehr Unsummen einfach so raushauen
- kein Staat dieser Welt würde sich wohl
heutzutage so etwas leisten wie das Apollo
Programm.
Dafür vielleicht aber eine Privatperson!
Und hier sind wir schon mitten im Vergleich.
Private Raumfahrtorganisationen wie Space
X sind nicht an politische Vorgaben gebunden
- eine große Chance.
Sie können ihre Raketen ins All schicken
wie und wann sie wollen und damit sogar Geld
verdienen.
In Zukunft ein riesiges Geschäftsfeld!
Oft wird das mit der Entwicklung der Computer
verglichen.
Damals, nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg waren es
riesige unhandliche Maschinen, die in großen
Gebäuden untergebracht wurden und kein normaler
Mensch konnte etwas damit anfangen.
Nur staatliche Unternehmen konnten sich diese
Maschinen leisten, bis dann private Firmen
in den Markt eingestiegen sind.
Die Computer wurden dadurch nicht nur preiswerter,
sondern auch kleiner und flexibler.
Mehr Leute kauften sie, auch für den privaten
Gebrauch, und so wurden die Computer noch
billiger.
Mittlerweile sind sie überall - auch in unseren
Autos, Telefonen und Fernsehgeräten.
Und genauso entwickelt sich die Raumfahrtindustrie
gerade.
Sie wird eine von Privatunternehmen geführte
Industrie.
Gerade haben Richard Branson die Ticketpreise
für einen Flug in den Erdorbit und Elon Musk
für Flüge zum Mars bekannt gegeben.
Eine riesen Chance, denn dadurch werden Raumflüge
nicht nur billiger, sondern auch einfacher
und sicherer werden.
Nicht nur Astronauten, sondern normale Menschen
wie du und ich werden vielleicht schon bald
ins All fliegen.
In Zukunft vielleicht sogar so routiniert
und unaufgeregt wie viele von ins Flugzeug
steigen, um Sommerurlaub zu machen.
Die private Raumfahrt kann so also Entwicklungen
vorantreiben, die die staatliche Raumfahrt
so nie hätte umsetzen können.
Auf der anderen Seite hat die staatlichen
Raumfahrt ja auch ihre Vorteile.
Hier geht es eben nicht mehr darum, “Erster”
zu sein - das hat jetzt die private Raumfahrt
übernommen.
Stattdessen hat die staatliche Raumfahrt sich
auf solide Grundlagenforschung konzentriert,
durch die wir den Weltraum immer besser verstehen
können.
Dennoch fehlt es leider eben an der Motivation,
eine spektakuläre und langfristig Mission
wie beispielsweise einen Flug auf den Mond
oder Mars anzugehen.
Das liegt, wie eben aber auch schon erwähnt,
an finanziellen und politischen Erwägungen.
Doch so stellen die privaten Betreiber wie
SpaceX den Raumfahrtagenturen die Existenzfrage:
Denn sie sind ihren Geldgeber, den Bürgern,
Rechenschaft schuldig.
Das hat bis vor kurzem funktioniert, denn
es gab einfach keine Alternative zu den staatlichen
Anbietern.
Doch NASA, ESA undsoweiter dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass sie einem gewissen Anspruch gerecht werden
müssen.
Sie haben die Aufgabe, den Fortschritt der
Gesellschaft zu sichern und moderne Technik
zu entwickeln.
Einen Schritt in die richtige Richtung hat
vielleicht das Großherzogtum Luxemburg im
Herbst 2018 gemacht.
Äh Luxemburg?
What?
Es hat eine eigene Weltraumagentur gegründet.
Das Ziel der Luxembourg Space Agency (LSA):
Private Unternehmen bei Weltraum-Forschungsprojekten
unterstützen und zwar mit staatlichen Mitteln.
Damit will das Großherzogtum eine führende
Rolle bei der wirtschaftlichen Nutzung des
Weltraums erlangen.
Große Pläne habe man in Sachen Asteroiden-Bergbau.
Hier will man beispielsweise Rohstoffe wie
Wasser- und Sauerstoff im All gewinnen und
für die Weltraumindustrie verfügbar machen.
Der rechtliche Rahmen für dieses Vorhaben
ist in Luxemburg als einziges Land in Europa
bereits geschaffen: Schon 2017 hatte man ein
Gesetz erlassen, das den Abbau von Rohstoffen
auf Asteroiden ermöglicht.
Auch wenn das Gesetz äußerst umstritten
ist, hatten sich daraufhin viele Firmen der
Weltraum-Branche ihre Zentralen nach Luxemburg
verlegt.
Die LSA wird jedenfalls eng mit der ESA zusammenarbeiten.
Erste konkrete Aktionen im Weltall sind jedoch
zeitnah noch nicht geplant.
Anders bei Elon Musk: Er steckt Milliarden
in seine Firma SpaceX, profitiert von der
staatlichen Forschung und alles andere kann
ihm egal sein.
Wenn er Menschen zum Mars schicken will, kann
er das ganz alleine entscheiden und auch umsetzen.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man das natürlich
auch wieder kritisch sehen.
Denn anders als staatliche Organisationen
muss er sich in seinem ganzen Tun nicht der
Öffentlichkeit gegenüber rechtfertigen,
denn er hat schließlich keine Verantwortung
uns gegenüber, wie und wofür er sein Geld
ausgibt.
All das hängt an ihm, einem Milliardär.
Genau wie auch an Jeff Bezos oder Richard
Branson, die ähnliche Visionen haben.
Theoretisch können sie aber auch von heute
auf morgen wieder auf der Spielfläche verschwinden
- das ist bei großen Organisationen wie der
NASA oder ESA nicht wirklich vorstellbar.
Und andererseits.
Wenn sie die Raumgahrtindustrie durch niedrige
Preise dominieren, haben sie plötzlich die
Macht im Weltraum.
Upsi.
Wäre es dann nicht viel verantwortungsvoller,
wenn der Weltraum nicht einzelnen Milliardären
bzw. seiner Firma gehört, sondern der ganzen
Gesellschaft?
Diese Überlegung ist allerdings schon jetzt
hinfällig, denn feststeht: Der Raumfahrt
stehen wilde Zeiten bevor.
Und das haben wir vor allem SpaceX allen anderen
Firmen zu verdanken, die den Weltraum erobern.
Die fundamentale Bedeutung der Raumfahrt.
Für dieses spannende Video hier klicken und
unbedingt den Kanal Neugierzone auch abonnieren,
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!